salut pierre barbizet revenu et il va
compléter notre catalogue musical
setc c'est chou balle toujours vivant
toujours été très imagé 13 états et
romantique
et puis comme grand roman tigana note
aussi qu'il est un brillant pianiste et
à grand musicien d'orchestre et un des
plus grands musiciens de tous les temps
est là et thérèse damour et a écrit des
races ont dit ambroise trop c'est fort
c'est pas mal mais basta il a aussi créé
beaucoup de musique descriptive
elle a écrit un jockey passant l'italie
reste qu'est ce que c'est une danse à
[Musique]
on
la politique
[Musique]
descriptif sénat police puis a eu après
les grands musées français alors de
mussy forêt et ravel alors ça c'est la
france qui est devenue le premier pays
du monde pour la musique ans à partir du
20e siècle et je voudrais jouer notre
jour du début si vous vous rappelez
et puis alors il ya aussi en hongrie et
en europe centrale des grands musiciens
vous avez dire ce que c'est que ça c'est
bartok prônée selon bartok c'était le
plus grand musicien aujourd'hui il est
mort depuis peu de temps
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est ce que c'est ça
et un traîneau ou la maison des vins
traîne une troïka ici c'est le gros lot
une toile qui va sur la neige qui sera
pour ceux qui s'en va oui mais voilà que
si vous avez si vous vous rappelez bien
tous ces grands musiciens
après vous pourrez aller au concert ou
entendre la radio autant dire vous savez
très bien où vous êtes vous pouvez vous
repérez vous comprenez mes enfants jury
ici un bien mais pas trop dur
moi j'ai demandé de me jouer ça si c'est
possible c'est une ans et vincent de la
vulve un sordide à l'heure on a fait une
transcription d'une très jolie musique
je comprends ça se vit comme ça où comme
ça en peu importe là c'est pas pareil
que dire de savoir un peu écoutez bien
[Musique]
oh
c'est dire bravo caselli a wish to sa
remarquable
ord alors baisse est enregistrée dans la
musique après bartok